for the comic book character turned
movie turned movie sequel well guess
what in the comic books he's gonna be a
chick that's right let's look at Thor
this is the Thor that you may know right
look at those muscles you like that Gina
don't you super into it Malcolm you're
into that those big pecs and those I go
I got one for the Bears you go me roar
of a better guy so that is that is store
right there and let's look at Thor's
hammer of course Thor is known for his
hammer and on his hammer it says whoever
holds this hammer if he be worthy shall
possess the power of Thor that's pretty
good this is very old manly right a lot
of muscles and manly but they are gonna
change Thor to a woman in the comic book
we've got a picture of the new lady Thor
oh that's right she is a handsome woman
she she is a feisty muscley chick and
she looks like she could do a lot of the
things that Thor is doing here we've got
a quote from the writer about this
change this is not she Thor this is not
lady Thor this is not Thor Rita this is
Thor this is the Thor of the Marvel
Universe but it's unlike any Thor we've
ever seen before so by the way just real
quick Chris Hemsworth will continue to
play Thor in the Marvel the Avengers
movies and I guess if they're gonna come
out with any others or sequels and
things like that but I think this is
this is kind of interesting when they
make these moves in comic books everyone
freaks you know you get a gay character
and Archie I thought Archie's stop being
printed you know forty years ago but
yeah exactly but anytime they do
anything in comics and they've had a
couple gay characters and comic books
comic books seem to get a little ahead
of the thing here so I assume you have
no problem with Thor becoming a woman
look man the only time I ever heard of
Thor in my life was when I was little
watching adventures in babysitting that
was the first time the Thor character
ever came I'm not a comic book person I
don't give a [ __ ]
however I did find a great meme if I may
share it with you this is great Disney
owns Marvel Marvel owns Thor Thor is the
son of a king Thor is now female that
means Thor is now a Disney Princess
and she but I mean I know I made a joke
about her you know gigantism but you
know she looks like a really powerful
chick and you know I there's we've
actually done stories on TYT about one
of the characters that they change to
african-american and people went in vain
so I can't imagine the reaction of this
is gonna be any different but she looks
like a good character you know I mean
she's got the the gigantic boobs and we
know she's female but she looks powerful
she looks strong she looks badass
Malcolm I know you're a traditionalist
you have major problems with well I mean
to me I don't know I didn't follow Thor
knows much more so I did it I looked up
Thor on Wikipedia to find out and what I
know about Thor is he has long flowing
golden locks he apparently is associated
with fertility and he's legendary for
fighting a giant snake and that doesn't
sound like a woman to me that sound like
a woman oh my god you're right no I
think that this is it's interesting I it
seems like the comic books it's a
marketing ploy obviously they want to
sell some comic books whatever but I
feel like comic books they they trail
the popular opinion I mean who a gay
character can you believe it I mean wow
that's shocking and and now what Captain
America is african-american and so I
feel like it's just whatever is becoming
accepted you know it gains my own
widespread acceptance and then the comic
books you know they follow along so so
we've got a female Thor black Captain
America and a gay character on an Archie
and ten years from now we'll have a like
a trans Thor
[Music]
the authority on Captain America will be
Muslim and the Fantastic Four will be
polyamorous I think what I assume that
people who are super traditionalist when
it comes to comics don't like is that
they're changing characters already in
progress they're not creating a new
powerful woman they're saying oh that
dude he's a chick now just get on board
and that we should we'd be okay with
those people that are just saying this
is about the lore of the thing if the
next Star Wars if they magically made
it really makes evader well you can I
guess you could have a you could have an
evil female gender but if you suddenly
if Luke Skywalker for the next one was
suddenly a woman he had a sex change in
the 30 years till the next one people
might be it would be upset if anybody
involved in Star Wars did something to
ruin the franchise that would be there
are there are people who not like thank
God that'll never have alright final
thought on this can you do anything
creatively without it being a political
statement can anyone do anything can a
comedian say anything can an artist
paint anything can a comic book without
everyone jumping on the political like
it's someone maybe this guy was just
like I'm just gonna do this and I'm not
putting a lot of thought and do it you
just can't write I loved his statement
this is a thaw Reena
this isn't lady Thor this is Thor like
this it's not because it it's not like
okay she's store but working it like
like we're gonna Disney Princess if I
her no it's just the character and
people hate that [ __ ] but they're the
same people that need to be sending
those people a muffin basket because
then we'd have nothing to talk about say
that even asking that question is a
political statement
that's why we've never had you on the
show for it is by just saying can't you
do anything without it being taken as a
political statement that you know no